this next section I have ready is if how
do we talk about this game without
getting super super spoilery so what
I've written down a running order is
uncharted 4 is a great game dosch
discuss okay ah so I completed it last
night no spoilers here whatsoever not
gonna get into that you guys are like
getting into it how many chapters I cuz
I'm not I played it hey ok so I'm ten
chapters in ok probably halfway ok yeah
ran halfway I'm 11 chapters in ok you
are also probably halfway yes and what
are your initial sort of feelings on it
at Peter Michael Hardy obviously
reviewed it for us tena down on gamespot
com and you founded the series already
coming into this what do you think about
nope nope I played the original and
charity for about two hours and thought
man this game plays like ass but did you
play two or three no okay never had a
chance um they're a lot better than one
that's what I've heard but now I kind of
want to go back honestly um if they're
anything like uncharted 4 which for me
what really struck me was the pacing is
really really good and the sort of
different beats that it hits they they
really inspire a sense of awe in so many
ways like whether it is a small
interaction between two characters and
that could be either someone reacting
anyway you don't usually see or a
character being oddly flawed when you
sort of look at them as someone who is
supposed to be like the the impeccable
hero right but then it's the incredible
landscapes and the vistas and and the
action moments that sort of appear not
really out of the blue but in such a way
that just feels like wow where did this
come from I'm in the middle of it right
now and then I'm swinging from a rope
over an ocean with like storms brewing
and it's like it's a very magical
experience it's not something that I
look to as a is a mechanically
challenging or risky game right but
that's okay i don't think every game has
to be that and for what uncharted does i
can't say i've played a game that does
that aspect as well in terms of the
pacing and the attention to detail
we think about it's obviously a
phenomenal game and I think what what
it's so special about uncharted games
they get a lot better after the first
one the first one you know it was an
extension of that post tomb raider
Indiana Jones you know tomb raiding
dungeon delving you know pushing buttons
on statues and making stuff happen as
it's progressed they've introduced more
of a story to him but it's still very
been very much been certainly in two and
three straight up action set-pieces i
think the real triumph of four is to
meld together what they do so well with
action which is i mean i think they're
the best in the business in terms of
straight up action set-pieces on in the
console generation combined with real
emotional weight and they do some stuff
not to talk specifically about the story
but there is stuff very early on this
introduced which gives drake's actions
that gives the characters that the the
tomb raiding you want to call it that
the the treasure-hunting stuff real
weight and real emotional purpose and
that's obviously stuff they've learned
from doing their child games but also
doing you know the last person you know
that that stuff i think has really shown
how much that stuff is bled through you
know there's obviously you can easily go
they've introduced and stealth stop more
stealth stuff from last of us but i
think the real thing that they've they
bought over from those games is the
emotional way that those games have yeah
and so in between the great action
set-pieces there is real drama that you
actually care about and it's the first
time in the series i would say that
there has been real drama that has real
consequences and really matters for the
characters and that that is what I think
contributes to it being such a really
great package yeah I've totally agreed
to the story stuff that they talk about
it as well as is very sort of like it's
not grandiose it's not the end of the
world stuff it's just simple human
problems and it's ridiculous to the game
which involves you murdering hundreds of
people has this like you know beautiful
little core tourist it's like a motion
of the story happening in the middle of
it and and that's what made me like for
a game like Peter said for a game that
like mechanically isn't like reinventing
the wheel by any means it's a competent
shooter and and I actually like the
traversal and I think it's
it more simple than something like Tomb
Raider and actually like it first um but
for a game that there has that sort of
doesn't have that moment to moment
amazing you know core gameplay I was I
thought propels to keep playing it all
the time because the story stuff is so
good and I don't know I think after
years of playing games you kind of get a
little bit burnt out on new environments
maybe they don't hit as hard as it was
but there's something about this game
it's gorgeous first of all but just the
design and it this way stuff looks it's
just I want to see more of it it was
like I was on holidays and I wanted to
go for a walk to enjoy it but also i
mean the previous games have always had
variety of location I mean it just in
the first three hours of playing this
game i think you visited like four
countries yeah yeah you know three
different environments and it you know
it it's amazing what it keeps throwing
at you in it will you tell us if it if
it keeps throwing that at your way
through but certainly where I'm at you
know however far into the game I feel
like it's always throwing something new
at me you know which obviously great
game design should do it should always
keep you know you shouldn't be coasting
too long you should always be
introducing new mechanics and new stuff
and yeah I mean it's you know there are
also masters of getting the most out of
current console this game action cry
mean is that I can't believe I can't
think of anything else that looks as
good as this or has looked as good as
this on any console generation
comparatively you know it's like it
really is just mind-blowing help with
this game looks perfect I mean it was
funny we were talking last week about
how you know you can't talk about any
good looking video game and it's
somebody mentioning the 30 60 thing this
game exists like perfectly in 30 frames
a second it's a cinematic experience and
it was never a moment where I thought oh
I wish this was like more fluid edit and
it looks unlike I were talking about the
playstation 2 4.5 stuff it's like this
thing this console is all right like if
they if somebody can get this out of the
console then like we're not doing too
bad between this and doom it's almost
like restore my most or my faith in the
current generation of consoles it's
detail they throw in like leaves just
dropping from the trees or dust being
thrown up and being caught by the
sunlight you know wait till you see the
mud oh but the car tracks it's like oh
my god well I remember the can't chase
demo from e3 right sharing that set
piece I mean
Santa theatre watching that with with
Randy and like it finished and I just
went that's the greatest action set
piece I've ever seen in it and being
demoed to me it like 83 is incredible
like them yeah and yet they had the time
to throw in all these ridiculous select
modes like things you can turn on after
the fact right yeah like play the game
you know in a kaleidoscope world or
whatever the hell I don't know what they
are but it's just incredible to me like
for all the lengths they go that most
studios never have the time or money to
go mmm they still found ways to go above
and beyond those expectations we have
from a studio like naughty dog yeah it's
incredible it's great game he played the
multiplayer I have not even touched it
yeah I suspect that's the case for a lot
of people I mean on to uncharted threes
multiplayer was it was better than I was
expecting I enjoyed it and I think a lot
of PlayStation we talked about it a bit
last week about like seven PlayStation
fans were sort of that was a really good
show scoop for them because like lobby
Xbox people playing gears war I don't
want fun you know this is a game that
was worth the asking price regardless of
its multiples even there so I'm sure
I'll jump into it at some stage but kind
of like doom actually I'm fine with this
as it is and it's in term I'll replay it
I'll happily we play uncharted and I
would never play a third person replay a
third person action game but this is the
whole yeah I'm already wanting to go
back and replay stuff I've played up to
this point mmm it's certainly the best
console exclusive I can remember in a
very long time yeah in terms of you know
console wars more we talk about things
making the difference to it being a
system seller yeah i mean this this is
it right it's only needed to sell more
systems this would do it already in a
pretty good situation yeah see you guys
excited to jump back in are you
interested in playing the multiplayer at
all are you just happy to get the
campaign over and done with i mean i'm a
dip in and try it by I'm out there's so
many other multiplayer games i'm
interested in playing right now or about
to come out tick-tock overwatch yeah
right so i mean there are you know and
i'd like to dig into doom a little bit
and play some of that i'm actually
really enjoying battleborn still so I
mean it's not like there's a shortage of
multiplayer stuff to do right now so
yeah it's I think it's gonna be a single
player experience for me yeah same cool
no interest yeah all right there you go
I'm trying to for a spoiler-free little
chinwag about that one Michael besadii
wasn't here for this chain while i was
gonna say okay that's things you lose
you can read his review and his got his
thoughts on uncharted 4
gamespot com it got a 10 and a 10 and I
think all three of us at the table would
agree that that is very very very very
worth it